you have threatened to recreate your  beautiful golden globes moment which you  must be so regretted because you've  talked about it everywhere you go yeah  ryan gosling is getting his award but  over here stealing the thunder  it's andrew garfield and ryan  reynolds so are you going to do it at  the oscars  it was a ridiculous thing i said to ryan  reynolds if you win  kiss me instead of your wife and  and he said yeah that's great and he and  the plan was that he would kind of move  move towards his wife and then and then  kind of last minute  and then he didn't win much to  our disappointment said i said to her we  can still just do it  and he was and he was game but and i  love the fact that it was so deep in the  background so you kind of have to kind  of look to see if it was actually